[Musique]
avant par les la chanson je voudrais
parler du cliquet juste sublissime il y
a un effet presque j'allais dire très
esthétique très aquatique très cosmique
mais c'est vrai que début je pensais
être habillée normalement toit puis je
maintiens mais il manque quelque chose
dans le clip on a su que j'avais les
cheveux comme ça le costume le costume
la tête à l'est et voilà si incroyable
ce costume il a fallu le faire aussi sur
mesure sur mesure n'était à l'opéra
bastille avec des petites mains c'était
magique
et c'est vrai pour revenir sur ce que tu
disais le côté aquatique et bat chaque
clip aura un thème déjà les quatre
premiers si on en fait 4 et le premier
et aquatiques et le second sera le sous
le signe du feu ce titre un parfait il
est chanté en français c'est de la pop
c'est là aussi assez épuré est ce que ça
peut préfigurer de de l'album qui arrive
oui il est un peu comme ça l'album il
est très spatial très aérien alpha c'est
mon monde intérieur que j'ai cherché
depuis longtemps tu vois on est passé
par les cherche midi d'une simple en
fait c'était alpha tout en assumant
julien voulzy mais c'est cette chose là
parce que j'ai toujours adoré l'espace
et je fais toujours la corrélation entre
le cosmos et les femmes la sensualité
tout ça tout est mêlé pour moi toi
comment est ce que l'amour de la musique
est arrivé est ce que c'est via ton père
laurent voulzy est-ce que c'est via tes
frères aussi qu'ils sont dans la musique
aussi dans ce milieu où est ce que tu as
d'autres inspirations pas trois ans
j'avais mon clavier je tapais la
première fois dessus c'est venu comme ça
et puis et puis après avec pierre
évidemment on a développé tout ça et ça
vient de là évidemment mon père la bière
pierre souchon le froid et on avait on a
vécu la même vie donc c'est sûr qu'on se
comprend et puis et puis petit on
faisait semblant de jouer avec des
raquettes on embête à nos parents je
t'avoue la vérité on est en bretagne en
faisait une evora spectacle il savoure
enfin spectacle incroyable je sais pas
ce que je suis parent maintenant quand
ma fille me disent ah ouais d'accord sur
wii vont vient donc ils montaient vers
ils nous regardaient puis en fait on
n'avait rien faisait semblant jouer de
la guitare mais sur des raquettes tu
vois
alors ce soir de renversant on va te
proposer un concert tu as pu rencontrer
avec amy estevan ouais tout à l'heure on
va aussi vous imposer un thème mais déjà
la rencontre avec camille vous étiez
jamais vu jamais et vous allez
travailler ensemble vous allez devoir
produire un titre pour nous ce soir
exactement avec un grand plaisir mais en
fait moi c'est un exercice qu'est ce qui
me fait un peu peur et puis on s'est
parlé de dire c'est que tu trembles
c'est parce que tu as froid c'est parce
que j'ai frôlé non c'est si j'ai peur je
le montre pas là j'ai froid et mais je
suis très heureux d'être là non mais
camille elle est super et quand on m'a
montré sa vidéo des buts je vais pas
dire évidemment qui c'était bon et puis
j'ai vu savez c'est quand j'ai entendu
sa voix
gfr vie c'est elle que j'ai vu est dans
un boy's et elle est on emprunte vocal
extraordinaire je suis très heureux de
faire ce truc là on s'est rencontré et
je crois qu'on est potes maintenant rage
adressé ce que j'aime avec les artistes
et que vous reconnaissez les voies c'est
ça qui vous fait vibrer ouais ça j'adore
ça mais les les voies et que les leurs
ont répété la tout à l'heure et je
regarde ses yeux et tu vois aussi ça tu
vois l'implication la voilà tout flamme
ouais la flamme la complicité le truc et
non va rester pas que c'est sur le thème
imposé c'est le silence
c'est quelque chose dont tu as
l'habitude oui j'aime ça j'aime me
retrouver seul mais j'aime aussi d'être
avec mes amis où j'aime la convivialité
mais j'aime aussi ça me fait pas peur le
science j'aime la campagne chevreuil
non mais ce soit on veut quand même
entendre de la musique julien je suis
chaud il est très très chaud notre
julien julien voulzy très content de
t'avoir dans renversant ainsi je t'écris
sur le sable une lettre d'amour en effet
mr
je